SMIL 800 assalamualaikum greetings of
peace to everybody all over the globe
thank you for tuning into the Deen show
and we're gonna be answering some of
your questions people want to know they
want to know about the fastest growing
way of life in the world today yet most
misunderstood and one confusion that
comes to mind is Eddie tell us what is
this on some of the emails that we get
they say can you tell us now you know
look we won't accept Islam and make
sense
worship the Creator not his creation and
you like that line up a man put a cow
here put the moon here the Sun here you
know and I said what should we worship
we want to worship the creator of all
these things not the creation but now
you have some of these weird things that
are associated with slum people beating
themselves blood all over the place and
attributing that with Islam I've seen
some of these things these weird like
mystical things that you know that just
go against your human nature so does
Islam have something to do with this no
it doesn't and we're gonna be clarified
someone eating another thing that comes
up Sunni and Shia God says in the Quran
that we've called you Muslims so now you
got so what am I supposed to be Sunni or
Shia so what's the difference what's the
difference we're going to be talking
about it with the host the Sheikh of
let's talk about it Kareem say jay-z
Kareem Zay Kareem here on the Deen show
we'll be right back
[Music]
this is the thing
back here on the Dean show with cher
cream from let's talk about it the TV
show that calls people in so we can talk
about it talking about the Dean I know I
get excited talking about this way of
life that brings peace because you know
the purpose and I just get so excited I
know you do too because you do the same
kind of program educating people hum did
a lot and thank you thank you for being
with us here on a Dean show love you a
lot energy in the room I'm delighted to
be with you again and Tom did is like a
local bar Thank You say time is always
short on these episodes so we're going
to get into this topic and the first
question that many of the not yet
Muslims also they write in because
everyone has the potential to submit to
the crater and they write in to say okay
what's the difference some people
sincerely want to know right because
they're looking to accept Islam but
they're like what is it just do I do
this Sunni thing or the see I think
others will use it and know they'll
attack you know Islam and say look you
guys you have all these different sects
in your religion because you know when
you mentioned some other religions I
have so many different denominations and
sects they know attack here so what's
the truth about this this Sunni and
Shiah what's the difference what's the
real difference here
well alhamdulillah salat wa salam ala
rasulillah eyeshadow la ilaha illallah
wahdahu la sharika lah ashhadu anna
muhammadan abduhu wa rasuluh let's
define the terms Xie Sun the word Shia
are linguistically is to align with
somebody and the technical term is
aligning with the family of the prophet
sallallaahu Luzon
but now doing this at the expense of the
hate and at the expense of having
animosity what the rest of the Ummah is
absolutely wrong what do I mean by that
aligning with the family of the prophet
salallahu alaihe salam to the extent
that they attribute divinity to them one
way or another they believe that they
know the unseen they believe that they
cannot go
without basically the intercession and
and and and consent and at the same time
they have animosity and hatred against
the rest of the Sahaba the companions of
the Prophet SAW Allah Allison this is
absolutely out of line and is not
correct
once we say Sunnah we really mean that
we follow the tradition of the Prophet
sallallaahu lesson and the term soon now
by the way emerged when these sects
already started developing in the Muslim
world and one of them is she she I mean
I've heard someone translation I can
also mean a sect absolutely it is a sect
word also can be used as a sensor sect
it is it's a mean sect
yeah a sect to align was okay with the
Shia and and the word is is used in the
Quran were in them in she RT Hill
Ibrahim yeah and from his line is a
brightness is basically a lining for
supporting or becoming alliance with
with with somebody in the sense but
again doing this at the expense of the
head of leather had a lot because we
know that when you attribute divinity to
anyone created I like to use the
creation that means you have invalidated
the auto hate because divinity belongs
to allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala and this is
something that the christians themselves
fall into remember christians they
worship is because of the love the
extreme love - Margie zhesan yes yeah
because of the extreme love they have
for him it's not what triggered it is is
the love that they had for prophet ISA
Jesus alayhi salat wa sallam the same
exact thing would be with with Shia the
belief or they pretend then my humble
opinion because listen the family of the
prophet salallahu alaihe salam will
never condone that the family of the
prophet sallallaahu oliver salim
we know from the serie from the
biography of ali IBN ABI talib
radiyallahu anh that he actually put
certain people to death because they
attribute the divinity to the hem
they said that he is Allah
that was at that time at that his time
there are people who came and said you
are Allah that they took one of the
Companions can you translate companion
likes for some people they say like you
know Jesus had his disciples all right
so this would be his Muhammad's decided
him as a God of gods
yeah and he himself said no way he said
get out of here would get out of here
with that so you now they attribute
divinity to to to the Imams
I'm talking about a role awful if not
really Mimi this is totally out of line
I mention Imams now Imams okay we know
look we know that Islam is about
worshipping like you just said the
Creator not his creation all divinity is
to the Creator all right so now you you
mentioned Ali who one is one of the
Companions already law and that we love
him right
and you mentioned some Imams now the day
that they give divinity to some Imams
nine dominant cause I'm the manager and
gamma not flow Haryana clear
well it's tomorrow year behind him never
an entered a truthful Allah Imam be a
given cone will be Eddie he could no
shade where is a car an NSA F corny yeah
okay when we talk about she are really
the mainstream Shia are if Nasri al Mme
are Rafat let's look at those three
terms
ethnic shreya they believe that there
are twelve imams starting with ali IBN
ABI talib radiyallahu anh and all of
them came from his offspring so these
are subgroups now insiders years
no no no no Emami or well out of those
do you have a lot of subgroups but an
amamiya rawa fidel if naturally they
believe that there are twelve imams
twelve imams in arms throughout history
one of them the last one is Mohammed
Amin al-husseini la scary he is now
hitting an eternal in her up in a place
called Samara for a thousand year now
and they are waiting for him to come out
a thousand years yeah somewhere they
actually every other day they go and
wait at the entrance of the tunnel with
the with the food and the camels and and
the horses for him to come out I mean is
a sci-fi I mean this is something you
can verify now hopefully that's from
their books so someone can't say look
this is like propaganda against from
their books
from the you want references will
provide it these viewers if you want to
just email idea and will provide it from
their books a little carry can see you
at let's talk about let's talk about so
in actually they believe that there are
twelve amounts but the only problem here
is attributing divinity to these Imams
and also if a sex example before you go
what what is when you say actually
attributing divinity denim who lay along
Memphis a Marathi all are the labor
illallah the only one who knows the
unseen in the heavens and the earth is
Allah Subhan Allah creator is the
creator was in my mind before you go
there when they came to Jesus peace be
upon him I you know they asked him about
you know about the day of judgment he
said no one knows neither the the the
the the Sun which that at that time
obviously meant a pious person nor the
angels but God alone even he said it
Muhammad said it some peace be upon him
but now how does these Imams have the
same exact thing actually they they
believe actually the Imams are better
than prophets oh yeah and the gibreel
alehissalaam is still stayed in earth
after the death of the prophet salallahu
alaihe salam to actually guide them and
reveal them reveal to them revelations
and so forth that's it not really Mamiya
there is another word for the mooches or
Rafat meaning what they rejected the
leadership of abu bakr siddiq
Omar and Othman and they labeled them to
be disbelievers because they believed
that they confiscated the leadership of
the Muslim world from Ali bin Abi Talib
rode alone and this is absolutely not
correct not not even Binstead so there
they are slandering you saying the
Companions who were with the Prophet
from the beginning for them Eddy only
seven companions stayed on Islam after
the death of the Prophet doesn't make
sense oh yeah it doesn't make sense
oh yeah the rest of the the companions
left the fold of Islam by accusing them
of hypocrisy or total or disbelief of
course which are almost alike so for
them is and that is where by the way the
word Sunnah came in place because guess
who conveyed the Sunnah to us who
conveyed Sunnah means the tradition of
the
the way can you say the way you were a
messenger selasa because our religion is
the quran and the way of the messenger
the way of the messenger explained the
quran can you say if you were living
during the time of Jesus of Moses you
were followed the revelation that they
had and their way absolute stunner
because look when I shot of the Aloha I
was asked about the character of the
prophets Allah silence what did she say
he's what a walking Quran so the
messenger in a way implements the
revelation the Quran in his character
and it becomes his way and now for you
to understand the core I only have to
look at his way now here it is why the
word Sunnah is important why because
when you label the Companions to be
disbelievers the companions are the
people who conveyed the Sunnah to us now
now look at this now if you open the
door hurry you're gonna find before you
go into the statement of the prophet
salallahu alaihe salam you're gonna find
something called the chain of narration
Albahari say I heard this hadith from
this person his shave his ship and he
heard it from another his ship that
chain of narration for the hadith to be
authentic must reach a companion now you
go to a CI and you tell him Abu Hurairah
Abu Hurairah no boric acid then you're
gonna reject what the messenger said
then the Sunnah is no longer there then
guess who explains and dictates what the
Quran means their Imams and that's where
that is why I'm telling you is we will
because we disagree on the source of the
religion and maybe I know you need to go
to break maybe we can come back and shed
more light because it's a very serious
business I don't know I know the Islam
is the fastest growing way of life we
have so many people coming over from
Catholicism Christianity from Hindu it
there except in Islam and they love the
pure monotheism of only worshiping God
the maker the creator and you know
people don't like this funky stuff about
worship being Imams and worshipping you
know men so they just left that to go
back to it that's that's and when I'm
asked by the way to to explain the
difference between Sunni and Shia in one
sentence I told them the Catholic
Christianity is what she is that you go
back to people the bulb and the
hierarchy kind of dictate what the
revelation means and in Islam is just a
guy just the Creator
we'll be back with more here ana Dean
shelf man and then the Sunnah of the
Prophet slicing them the fact that you
have an application so you have you know
the beauty of this lab is that not only
is our text our scripture preserved so
flawlessly but the interpretation of the
scripture is preserved so flawlessly
which is the prophets all along our
DSM's example the Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him as I shall be a lot and they
Allah be pleased with her explained
today you know I explained he was a
walking or Adam which is so if I can't
understand this word I can just go to
the Prophet slice on his wife likens I
can see even the Sunnah has been
preserved flawlessly in comes back here
on the DS showing as answering helping
clarify souvenirs she I now you know
usually when people ask the question
what's the difference
and the basic response is there was a
political political difference that you
know like you had mentioned in the
beginning after the last and final
messenger to mankind the problem having
peace be upon him who's the brother to
Jesus Moses Abraham came with the same
message where should the Creator not his
creation when he died now he you had his
his best of friends his companions in
modern day you know slaying you know
that his homeboys can say his homeboys
they would have Titus closest now did
Ali have a problem now they'll say that
look
Abu Bakr he was next to be the Caliph
how can you translate caliphs president
what are you say for in English the
vice-gerent the leader right so so most
people know that ok there was just this
group wanted Ali to be you know the
there's more to it now there's much more
that's not really the case that's not
the case ok let's establish this let
stablish this the question that we need
to ask ourselves first did the prophet
sallallaahu alia Selim name anyone in
his place after his death the answer is
no would the bluff it's Allah who are
you sellin
name anyone even if it is a leave never
eat a liver of the Ilan I'm telling you
the caliber of that generation will not
even thought about seeing no to it
because we know when we we know how they
respond to
and of Allah and His Messenger so the
basic rule here lhasa fill masala the
prophet sallallaahu Oliver Selim never
named somebody of course the Shia
because they do not follow our like I
mentioned before because they label
almost 99.999 of the Companions to be
disbelievers that's why they reject the
Sunna so they have their own sources and
kapha Collini other books that they
follow Mahadeo Muslim for them are not
even in the picture so they come up with
an author they claim hadith a dear home
they say when the prophet salallahu
alaihe salam returned from his farewell
hajj he stopped at a place called vedere
home and there he delivered a sermon and
he named Ali to be his follower guess
what we don't even have a trace of this
author in our in our son we don't listen
you know how many people meet had with
the prophet sallallaahu I'll sell and
farewell hug a hundred the records say a
hundred two hundred and twenty thousand
you wanna tell me that that number of
people none of them narrated this hadith
we only find this hadith in in their
books impossible that hadith not even
weak fabricated in the books of the
people of son we have an authentic
hadith where I live now with Holly what
are the Allah and during the time of the
fitna during the time of the actual
fighting that took place later on in
history during his reign he was asked by
the people in era did the prophet
salallahu alaihe sell them by accident
by allah you tell us did the prophet
sallallaahu Selim name you to be his his
breed Assessor to be his the one to take
over the OMA after his death video by
Allah with the prophets allah assalamu
would have done that I would have fought
all the Muslims why because it's a
command from Allah and His Messenger I
would not have let go Ali gave him the
pledge to abu bakr siddiq let you mean
bhaiyya
that you are my ameer you are my leader
he gave it to Omar he gave it to off man
he didn't objector no he used to work
for them he used to be the coffee he
used to be called sir I used to be the
judge for all of those during so he was
in compliance with every time
all of this stuff made up later on by a
man came from Yemen his name is Abdul
Leibniz ever
yeah originally he was one of the people
of the book the guy is a heater off of
Islam and and and the fact that Islam
emerged and and and and got all this
real state in the face of this earth he
triggered all of this later on during
the time of us Maranatha nordella
Valastro I wanna say lost with the
prophets allah salem would have named
anyone after him to be his successor
that's the word we were looking for
successor
none of the Sahaba would even have
questioned that but he hinted that Abu
Bakr Siddiq should be the one how him a
Methuselah when he became very ill and
sick he more than one occasion more
about current values on living as
command Abu Bakr to lead the Muslims and
Saleh command Abu Bakr to lead the
Muslims and Saleh at one time by the way
ad in one of the and the hadith are
authentic and I'm willing to furnish
that the references for you if I am
asked at one time he heard the voice of
Alma he said yeah but la while most
Allah refuses and the Muslims refused
that anybody would be the leader of the
a man but he did not say our work is the
email but he said he should lead the
salah in a way the Sahaba understood
from that that he should be the one who
takes off now the earth and look how it
happened you know after the death of our
office Allah Holly Selim ordering Yanni
after his around his burial time the
alums are the original dwellers of
Medina they were afraid that Medina
would be attacked so they men they went
and met in a place called a fat man
aside a place like a meeting place a
gathering place in order to talk about
having a leader because the the suburbs
of Medina these big ones are about to
attack Medina knowing that the prophet
sallallaahu Salim is dead so they they
thought about meeting and appointing
somebody to be the leader of Medina abu
bakr siddiq love the elan warmer another
abate algebra as soon as they learned
this they went to that meaning and right
there they address them they said listen
you know the Prophet SAW Rafael and said
that the leader should be from Quraysh
and so forth and I would like or honor
or evade he actually raised
both of their hands were Aveda Allah The
Messenger of Allah said Amina luma the
trustworthy luma Omar you know what the
prophetess Ellen said about him the
normal eye no one should take precedence
ahead of you and that's how the whole
thing emerged it was not something that
is planned or something so a reward they
say the Sahaba they stole they
confiscated the leadership and and they
curse them yeah honey for them to say
you see for us Eddie to see Subhan Allah
Subhan Allah Subhan Allah o Allah
cursey and an octal KO flag for the one
who conveys this belief is not a
disbeliever this is disbelief for me oh
look at this our lockers Abu Bakr all
lockers or mercy
it's a total different sci fi religion
and and and it just promotes hate there
is too much heat into it imagine to
worship Allah here you say Allah curses
this Allah curses that in a land we
don't do that we don't do we ask people
that Allah guides them and and so forth
but I wouldn't say I think it should be
worthy to say that not all this year a
lot of the Shia are blind followers they
just don't know they just don't know
they are victims of bad information out
there and that is why I always because I
get asked that in my show all the time
and some people sometimes they just call
to give me a hard time about the subject
because they know where I stand on the
issues I tell them brothers I tell my
brothers and sisters in Islam the Shia
they deserve Dawa exactly that our
calling to the right Dean to the right
religion exactly like the Jews and the
Christians call them to talk to the
right way explain to them what happened
in a kind in a nice way because they
deserve that way they deserve to be
equal to but don't compromise don't mix
with them don't try to to compromise and
accept what they what they promote of
teachings and because if you actually
believe it it takes you out of the fold
of Islam we got a question coming and
now someone is asked that look that this
person loves to share the message of
peace peace acquire by submission to the
will of God Islam it makes sense
worshipping God pure monotheism but now
the purse
has been asked a question about by a not
yet Muslim anonymous I'm asking about
these practices in Islam where they have
this beating and you see these kids who
are all bloodied up and now he's like
how is this part of my religion
absolutely not
listen that the 10th day of in Muharram
which is the Day of Ashura
you see really this day shows you two
sects again III when I'm ABI I hope I
have time to so this has nothing to do
you know these these kids are people
beating each other these weird things
let me just say something quickly I'm
hoping to do if it's not absolutely but
our messengers said this listen we're
gonna end up 73 sects no question this
hadith sahih a very famous hadith famous
hadith in the Sunna of the Prophet SAW
Salim you cannot even reject it but
again when we say this were not
promoting this unity were not we're not
actually we have a lot of text that
commands us to be united what does he
move the hands of Allah is with the GEMA
and so forth but if it happens that you
end up with this sect Hollis kata this
is the father of allah subhanaw taala
so talking about sects Annie were not
promoting it no or not actually we must
strive to be united but we cannot be
united on falsehood we have to be united
in truth now the day the 10 day from
Muharram shows you two sect in Islam a
sect called she are offered and now acid
the Day of Ashura I'm talking about the
day for sure people who grieve too much
extreme excessive sorrow and excessive
joy now ass of are the people who are
lining with of man against Ali and now
offered the people who are aligning with
ally against of man so on that day you
see the the Shia are offered beating
themselves up this has nothing to do
with the religion rasul allah allah wa
sallam said that about grieving in
alkali belly and the heart grieves when
his son died when his son died the heart
grieves the i could shed tears but we do
not say or do anything or act in a way
that ignorant that shows our rebellion
against the decree of allah subhana WA
Ta'ala so now the day of ashura the
tenth day fell Muharram is actually a
day that should connect us with the
early muslims with moosa alaih-is-salaam
this is the day when a rasoolallah Valeo
salam was asked
when he asked that you were the Jews the
people of the book in Medina why are you
fasting this is this is a day when Allah
saved Musa and his followers from the
fear and his gang the prophets Allah
Allahu Alem City we have more of a claim
to mooses than them and he commanded the
Sahaba to fast
so we're fasting this day to connect us
with the early Muslims but you find
these sects on that day which which
happened to be the day that were saying
all of the al-amin the grandson of the
Prophet SAW sallam was killed
well he was killed in that day but they
used this day now to bring up in a
Maserati and heat and and and divide the
Ummah
we are aligning with the family of the
Prophet over again is the feather but
but the people of the sunnah know we
observe a bad on that day for that
purpose
it's the natural way islam is the
natural way it makes sense and no none
of these strange incantations
superstitions that just go against your
your very nature we're gonna be right
back with more here on the deen show so
cool who allah who say he allows one God
is one the maker America exactly a lot
of some men lost self sufficient he
doesn't need food or drink he doesn't
need to rest on the seventh day ok I
really had a problem with that even
before I do anything about Islam God
resting sounds like a weak guy yeah
lemme eyelid well I'm you let he begets
not he doesn't have any children nor was
he a child or born of anything or anyone
well I'm yeah cool out before I die and
there's nothing co-equal or comparable
to him at all nobody nothing there's
nobody nobody is comparable to the
Creator nothing yeah and that right
there was in his essence what I believe
naturally
she had often mistranslated as holy war
the word jihad means to struggle Islam
does not preach violence it does not
preach vicious holy war it certainly
does not condone terror and suicide
bombing Islam preaches compassion
tolerance and justice find the truth
about Islam call toll-free 877 why Islam
order your free copy of the Quran today
[Music]
if allies by my side I am Not Afraid
back here on the Dean show and we're
helping you understand out of the love
because we got a lot of love that's
we're out there trying to educate the
people and many people like you said
they just don't know you know just you
know like many of our brothers in
humanity the Christian just slide in on
Sunday worshipping Jesus father son Holy
Ghost but when you talk to him he
explained to him with love we've cared
that look Jesus never call people to
worship him Jesus called people to
worship God and he start thinking he
said man that makes sense worship the
Creator not his creation and many of
them they've submit and they become
those who have submitted to the will
have got Muslims and many of the people
out there that we're talking about
hopefully God willing
they can come around and start doing the
right thing I want to share a story with
you when I went to Hajj and I met one
scholar there and he was sick you know
when you go to Hajj a lot of people to
end up you know some of them get they
end up what is it what is it about
sometimes you just get sick sometimes
the ten cities Amina yeah the the the
sickness of Hajj is gold yeah that you
know this is a la puta five years right
so we went to see one Sheikh and he said
you know who's he he couldn't talk or
anything you know but then before he
left he came and said salams to us and
he told I mean he told us just a couple
words or one word was it - he said she
said toe heat that means hold on to toe
he'd it's like hold on to the monotheism
so what I've learned from studying over
the years what's helped me and many
differentiate you know what the truth is
from falsehood is knowing this
monotheism knowing that there's only one
creator that all worship is for him that
he has the perfect names and attributes
so when someone starts calling about you
know their teacher their Sheikh is
somewhere floating up in the heavens you
know someone who knows the unseen you
know that you that they want me the word
like that that it lies moment that so
now now you're talking about people
worshipping a companion of the Prophet
making these Imams with divine
attributes that's a no-no right there
that's a telltale sign isn't ejectives
you'll right away I mean I know you're
addressing a lot of you
people who are maybe interested in Islam
at its own in Islam when people become
divine when people can and we mean by
the attribute divine means the meaning
the attributes of divinity the knowledge
of the unseen
that is one harming benefiting that they
can cause harm to fall upon you or
benefit you give an example like someone
says look I want a baby girl absolutely
right and then and then they'll do some
special wudu stuff you know none of that
idea right all that stuff lucky charms
anything that takes your attention away
from your creator say no to it and this
is listen the Prophet SAW Allah Allah
Allah Subhan Allah he told us this he
said later truly come an opportunist
Arab memory
don't you ever praise me like the
Christians brazed the son of Maryam and
the slave of Allah and His Messenger
that's all and I'm telling you Eddy I'm
telling you I'm really skeptical that
they do love the family of the prophets
Allah Allah I am really if there are
people who love the family of the
Prophet sallallaahu Selim truly are the
followers of the Sunnah of the Prophet
SAW Lawson I'm telling you what law he
will love them dearly
we love la Li la la la vez al Jaffa we
love them we love his family how in the
world that we we we people who follow
the Sunnah of the Prophet SAW Salam
would have anything against the family
of the Prophet Allah Allah
this is the family of our messenger come
on we cannot I mean but we love them the
way that Allah wants us to love them
that we don't want to give them special
status and remember Eddie remember Eddie
the first shidduch
shared meaning association in worship
with allah subhanaw taala
was placed in earth was that shit of
excessive love for human beings you know
between adam and noah based on hadith of
Mabus there were ten centuries thousand
years no heat no shark at all but the
people had five righteous people
what dance were on yahoo thea aqua
nasara they messed them they best passed
away and they missed them
later on they made idols of them
because they miss them
well Adele ik our schoolers and prophet
nooh alehsalaam came and spent nine
hundred and fifty years to take them
away from this they why that love that
is why when they like our schoolers they
had a very famous line they say min
owlusa I would ear till barking a Lulu
Oh Phil a father one of the greatest
gate to miss guidance that you
exaggerate regarding the status of a
human being
well indirect therefore we were banned
from be you know I cannot please you I
cannot I cannot please myself when I
breeze you a said oh Allah I think he is
good because I don't know because there
is a hard deal that that is engaged and
the one who knows what's in the heart is
Allah subhanAllah a shadow the important
thing is this is a big sensor you know
the word sensor sensor for non-muslims
if you seek in the truth if you find a
Muslim talking to you about that Imam is
divine that shift tariqa is divine that
that is divine divine means here he's
holy he has some attributes of holiness
he can turn things around for his HiFi
things for you stop and look for the
truth the truth will lead you to Allah
subhana WA Ta'ala and abiding by the
that's one of his mercy so these like
supernatural things that they try to
make a human being do know that's a big
that's a big sensor and I'm telling you
especially Christians they would know it
because Christians they came because of
this I mean the culture of Christianity
Saints and I mean they that is why the
overwhelming majority of people who
accept Islam they if I left all that oh
yeah
I don't worship that's why in worship
st. Lucia that's why it's very hard for
the work of Shia Islam is not successful
in the Christian world because of that
because immediately they they figure it
out they figure it out
we ask Allah subhana WA Ta'ala to guide
us but certainly we need to promote the
true teachings of Islam which is like
you said that at the beginning of the
segment
monotheism that we hate pure manaphy is
and people can look you if they want
more on this topic they want to they
want some of these references I can
reach you where well I have Kareem Abu
Zeid calm which is a website it has all
my lectures and work there I have a
YouTube channel under my knee
Kareem Abouzeid or Aslam weigh 71 I
called it and there is a Facebook and
you know Islam Q&A that TV Guide us that
TV let's talk about it let's talk about
it if you google any of that you should
be able to get in touch and shake thank
you very much for being with us today
well yeah thank you and I hope we
answered your question we want the best
for all of mankind that's where we're
trying to educate mankind on the way of
light that's from the Creator the way
the Sunnah the same way of life that
Abraham lived Moses lived Jesus live
they were on that way that was pleasing
that are created they never worshiped
men women animals stars birds Imams
Jesus never worship his companions or
himself or call people to worship
anything in creation that's a red light
so if you're confused about anything who
can uncuff use you the Creator pray to
him alone and sincerely earnestly ask
him for guidance and he will say
facilitate away he'll facilitate away so
if you have any further questions give
us a call 1 800 662 to seeing you next
time here on the Deen show until then
peace be with you